[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo le meilleur à l'assemblée et au
sénat et cette semaine nous accueillons
roger karoutchi
bonjour bonjour jai karoutchi vous êtes
sénateur les républicains des
hauts-de-seine bonjour j'ai karoutchi on
va commencer bien par votre carte
d'identité donc vous êtes né roger
karoutchi à casablanca au maroc
vous êtes sénateur les républicains des
hauts-de-seine katia l'a dit élu pour la
première fois au sénat il y à 20 en deux
décennies demande a interrompu par deux
ans d'expérience ministérielle sous
nicolas sarkozy dont vous restez
d'ailleurs l'un des fidèles votre signe
distinctif roger karoutchi
votre sens de la formule vous êtes ce
qu'on appelle chez les journalistes
un bon client alors on espère qu
aujourd'hui vous allez être fidèle à
votre réputation
je vais tâcher autant mais montrez moi
d'abord ce que vous avez comme carte
d'identité
hall a montré mais on va vous dire aussi
le menu de cette émission et à la hune
roger karouchi le port du voile qui fait
polémique la question divise au sein
même de la majorité
l'assemblée poursuit le marathon
budgétaire elle a donné son feu vert à 5
milliards de baisses d'impôts pour les
ménages
et puis les pouvoirs de police du maire
seront renforcés c'est la disposition
phare votée cette semaine dans le cadre
du projet de loi sur le statut de l'élu
et on commence par le premier sujet de
cette semaine le débat polémique sur le
port du voile
[Musique]
faut-il légiférer pour interdire le
voile aux accompagnants de sorties
scolaires pour la droite sénatoriale la
réponse est oui
pour le gouvernement la réponse est non
le sujet a enflammé l'hémicycle du sénat
mercredi que michael spielberg
c'est un vieux débat qui fait de nouveau
rage depuis le 11 octobre ce jour-là un
élu du rassemblement national demande à
une femme accompagnant des élèves au
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté d'enlever son voile islamique
la vidéo fait le buzz et à droite on
assure avoir la solution une loi mûri
depuis longtemps pour interdire les
signes religieux dans le cadre scolaire
et qui sera examiné au sénat le 29
octobre prochain
nous considérons que les sorties
scolaires c'est la prolongation de
l'école c'est l'école la classe hors les
murs et je pense que il ya une exigence
de neutralité et de laïcité renforcée à
l'école pourquoi parce qu'on à faire des
jeunes à des consciences en formation ni
voile ni loi c'est la position du
ministre de l'éducation qui ne satisfait
évidemment pas la droite sénatoriale
nous ne souhaitons pas une loi parce
qu'une loi créerait plus de problèmes
que de solutions
autrement dit elles seraient
contreproductives en revanche et je les
dis le voile n'est pas souhaitable parce
que en effet nous ne souhaitons pas que
ce soit un élément qui puisse être
interprété comme du prosélytisme dans
ses sorties scolaires je peux pas croire
qu'aujourd'hui vous puissiez raté une
occasion de marquer une réelle volonté
de lutter contre les velléités de
l'islamisme en france alors que deux
français sur trois sont prêts à soutenir
cette loi qui interdit le voile pendant
les sorties scolaires
franchement je trouve que c'est un
manque de courage pour edouard philippe
l'objectif c'est la lutte contre la
radicalisation et le communautarisme
faire en sorte d'exercer un contrôle
beaucoup plus strictes sur les écoles
hors contrat au moment de leur création
faire en sorte de pouvoir avoir un
contrôle beaucoup plus strictes sur les
enfants déscolarisés sur les réseaux
leur déscolarisation et sur le contenu
de l'éducation qu'ils reçoivent à
domicile
voilà à mon avis des sujets qui sont
bien plus importants
bien plus porteur que la simple
évocation de la loi qui a été évoqué
assemblée nationale et sénat auront à se
prononcer sur la question dans les jours
à venir avec deux propositions de loi
qui seront soutenus par certains élus de
la majorité présidentielle
roger karoutchi pour votre groupe c'est
clair il faut interdire le voile aux
accompagnantes de sorties scolaires est
ce que c'est vraiment la priorité pour
lutter contre le communautarisme encore
la radicalisation
si on avait une priorité absolue ça se
saurait depuis longtemps
la vérité c'est que je trouve que le
gouvernement n'est pas courageux ou plus
exactement qu'il te fait beaucoup de
déclarations etc a pas beaucoup d'actes
derrière moi j'étais enseignant dans un
établissement difficile d'une banlieue
difficile mais c'était il ya 20 ou 25
ans et quand on faisait des sorties
scolaires les accompagnantes y compris
les accompagnantes musulmane et dans
l'établissement où j'étais elle avait
beaucoup ne portait pas de voile la
vérité c'est que les choses ont changé
et qu'il faut s'adapter
moi je considère que l'école
l'établissement scolaire s'est pas
uniquement l'établissement scolaire à
l'intérieur des murs aussi coloniser
or des bulles ou dit oui quand ce n'est
pas ta yo mais quand vous avez des
élèves que vous enseignez que vous les a
menés dans des sorties scolaires que
vous les amener faire des visites
c'est l'école c'est pas d'un coup à
l'intérieur c'est neutre
à l'extérieur tout est possible et
parlant c'est pas des agents du service
public je suis d'accord mais si vous
voulez faire en sorte que les choses
soient claires et pour éviter la scène
que je trouve franchement à la fois
dérisoire méprisable et au de ce qui
s'est passé au conseil régional de
bourgogne franche comté parce que on
peut mettre des règles il faut pas
s'attaquer aux personnes
ce que c'est tout pour l'instant c'est
bien mais elle avait le droit d'y aller
non mais
c'est pas le sujet puisque alors je ne
sais pas ce que sont les règles internes
du conseil régional en tout cas en tant
que compagnon elle avait le droit
moi je trouve que mettre des règles
savait qu est ce qui se passe quand même
en réalité c'est que depuis un an deux
ans trois ans vous voyez bien des
associations envoie des femmes en
burqini dans les piscines
nous vous disiez à une
instrumentalisation par présente
alisation je dis pas que derrière une
espèce de complot et faut pas exagérer
mais il ya une tentation d'affirmation
identitaire qui n'a pas lieu d'être
quand on est dans une sortie scolaire
l'école la sortie scolaire pour moi et
dans l'ensemble je prendrais
j'interviendrai dans le débat le 29
octobre au sénat
et je veux dire un certain nombre de
choses est-ce que vous pensez que toutes
les femmes voilées aujourd'hui sont les
porte-parole d'un islam politique veut
non non si on généralise ont réduit la
portée de ce que l'on dit moi j'ai vécu
je suis né est importé alors gager
partie gamin mais je vais vous dire à
l'époque
y a pas de femmes voilées à casablanca
un important c'était 90% de musulmans
mais pas de femmes voilées
d'ailleurs au maroc finalement bientôt
il y aura peut-être pas tant que ça de
femme voilée parce que le roi sa famille
ne donne pas cet exemple là mais il ya
une situation compliquée c'est vrai que
vous auriez ici ou là des femmes voilées
dans la rue parce que réellement c'est
leur conviction à leur mode de vie
personne ne dira et là vous dites qu'il
ya autre chose les maintenances que des
cons vision dans que dans certaines
mosquées salafistes dans certaines
associations ont fait du prosélytisme
sur le thème porter le voile c'est une
affirmation de ce que nous on est là on
sort de la conviction personnelle
pourrait dans une affirmation qui
sincèrement en tout cas l'école n'a pas
lieu d'être en tout cas il ya le parfait
contre-exemple un sédatif albanese
athènes qui est la mère de la première
victime de mohamed merah elle porte un
voile et en même temps un livre bien un
combat contre le communautarisme et la
radicalisation c'est bien la preuve
qu'il ya autant d'années je suis je suis
entièrement d'accord sauf que moi je ne
sais pas quelle est la vie
de latifa sur les sorties scolaires
mais elle se plie aux règles de la
république a toujours et c'est sa force
et c'est comme ça qu'elle influence je
suis sûr qu on lui dirait madame alors
pas d'enfants à ma connaissance en âge
scolaire
mais vous allez être un compagnon et il
faut pas porter de voile elle se
plierait aux règles de la république
la république c'est pas à géométrie
variable moi je pense que je ne suis pas
contre le fait que des femmes musulmanes
qui croient qu'ils pensent danser le jeu
puisse porter plus d'ailleurs le foulard
que le voile parce que on mélange un peu
tout là on ne dissimule pas le visage
mais pas dans l'école avant dans les
règles de la laïcité
on a bien compris votre position la
question du voile divise aussi roger
karoutchi au sein de la majorité la
députée david en marche aurore bergé a
suscité le trouble parmi ses collègues
annonçant qu'elle voterait la future
proposition de loi d'eric ciotti pour
interdire le voile lors des sorties
scolaires écoutés mais pas m'empêcher
vidant de voter cette proposition de loi
si elle est déposée uniquement parce que
celui qui la porterait ne me convient
pas sur l'ensemble des idées qu'ils
proposent à voter la proposition de loi
d'eric ciotti fleuret ce parc comprend
oui je les dis très clairement je pense
que le message est exactement celui ci
n'utilisait pas mon nom pour une cause
qui n'est pas la mienne et qui n'est pas
à ce jour celle de mon parti donc
puisque twitter a été son mode
d'expression ça a été de réponses mais
qui se voulait simple de dix ans c'est
pas un sujet qui a été débattue ont
groupés arrêté en groupe
est ce cette parole là ne doit pas être
portés en mon nom et comme les porte
parole du mouvement moi je ne voulais
pas qui de confusion là dessus alors
voilà il ya eu un peu de cacophonie de
voix sur le sujet on va pas chaque hiver
des relations publiques
enfin franchement quand j'entends
l'arabe alors comment comment ça pas été
débattue en groupe parce que maintenant
les députés où les sénateurs n'existe
plus individuellement qu'il faut
respecter la liberté d'expression
- il ferait beau voir quand même comme
disent voilà ce que je dois penser voilà
ce que je dois au berger a eu raison de
baisses bien sûr que là une raison bien
sûr c'est du pain béni pour vous quand
même de voir émerger
ce débat qui renforce votre base à
droite et qui fracturent on voit la
majorité gouvernementale
qu'est ce qui renforce notre base à
droite vous croyez pas que le président
la république qui court après
l'électorat de droite il fait trois
discours sur l'immigration il se passe
rien derrière il n'y a pas un acte n'a
pas un vote
il n'y a pas une décision mais on est
dans l'espèce de de négation du débat
public par le fait de faire dans la
confusion les propos valent les actes et
ben non
nous on veut des actes et il faut
rouvrir le débat après la dernière loi
qui pour vous il faut rouvrir le débat
sur ce quart des voix la loi de 2000 cas
la loi de 2004 à l'époque
franchement le j'étais déjà au cedar et
le la loi dit ça évolue et ris parce
qu'en 15 ans le débat sur le voile
d'ailleurs la loi de 2004 à l'intérieur
des écoles a très bien fonctionné et
aujourd'hui il ya très peu de problèmes
à l'intérieur des établissements
scolaires sauf que la loi de 2004 ne
s'était pas étendue aux sorties
scolaires parce qu'à l'époque
franchement c'était pas un sujet pas un
problème mais ça n'avait pas été évoqué
aujourd'hui moi je pense qu'il faut dire
l'école c'est un bloc
voilà dans ce bloc là et c'est plus
simple pour tout le monde ça nous
évitera les cris ça évitera les
humiliations ça évitera le mépris et
chacun respecte les règles de la
république la recherche de
clarifications donc oui alors on passait
au deuxième sujet de cette émission tout
autre chose la baisse de l'impôt sur le
revenu qui a été voté
[Musique]
le marathon budgétaire se poursuit à
l'assemblée nationale la partie recettes
du projet de loi doit être voté mardi
prochain en attendant la mesure phare de
ce plf 2020 a été voté la baisse des
impôts fanny die je vais mettre aux voix
l'article 2 pour 65 contre 3 il est donc
adopté la baisse de l'impôt sur le
revenu pour les ménages c'est la mesure
phare du projet de loi de budget pour
l'année prochaine promise par emmanuel
macron en réponse à la crise dès gilet
jaune
elle entrera en vigueur dès le mois de
janvier mission accomplie s'est félicité
le ministre des comptes publics gérald
darmanin dans l'hémicycle donc il n'y a
pas de loup dans la bergerie encore
moins dans le flou ce qui est sûr c'est
que 1 la majorité parlementaire a coupé
la province du présent de la réplique de
pc de 5 milliards l'impôt sur le revenu
et qu'en moyenne ces 300 euros de
pouvoir d'achat redonna donc aux ados
concitoyens concrètement le gain moyen
pour les 12 millions de foyers soumis à
la première tranche de l'impôt sur le
revenu sera de 350 euros et 280 euros en
moyenne pour les 5 millions de foyers de
la tranche suivante une mesure soutenue
par la droite qui a tout de même exprimé
quelques nuances avec le gouvernement
nous contestons effectivement le chiffre
que vous annoncez en indiquant un cadeau
fiscal de 2 5 milliards d'euros parce
que avant ce cadeau fiscal
il y à une augmentation de l'impôt
tandis qu'à des degrés divers la gauche
et a critiqué voire dénoncer les
modalités de cette baisse d'impôts je
rappelle que les baisses d'impôt de 5
milliards sur l'impôt sur le revenu ça
va faire cinq milliards de moins de
dépenses publiques
si on voulait se faire vous allez finir
par supprimer l'impôt sur le revenu
parce que certes hier les foyers
modestes qui vont en profiter mais il ya
aussi des ménages qu'on peut qualifier
de ménages aisés le vat de la partie
recettes du budget aura lieu mardi dans
l'hémicycle
auximines 9 milliards de baisses
d'impôts j'ai commencé dans cinq
milliards pour le seul impôt pour le
revenu ce que vous dites bravo le
gouvernement a raison de baisser les
impôts
ah mais moi je prends tous toutes les
bonnes nouvelles sont bonnes a pas mal
sais pas je veux pas faire le difficile
réalité
le vrai sujet c'est que là il ya une
baisse factuel pas énorme puisque c'est
sur plusieurs millions de ménages
modestes pour 5 milliards
l'histoire de la taxe d'habitation n'est
pas claire parce qu'en réalité on voit
bien qu'en parallèle la taxe foncière
augmente mais sur la baisse de l'impôt
sur le revenu c'est bien je pense que le
gouvernement a dû faire plus parce que
nous avons eu 5 7 ans d'augmentation
d'impôts considérable donc en réalité
réajustement justement très modeste par
rapport à la réalité de ce que l'on a
subi et le problème c'est qu'en
parallèle on continue laissé filer la
dette et le déficit qu'il faudra bien
rembourser un jour via kirby et on vit à
crédit est malheureusement très
longtemps on joue sur les taux d'intérêt
très bas
le jour ses taux d'intérêt remontent je
sais pas comment fera pour rembourser en
revanche sont laissés sur le carreau
dans ce budget quand on analyse les 10%
les plus riches donc avait eu lieu en
début de quinquennat puis aussi les 10%
les plus pauvres ceux qui ne payent pas
d'impôts qu'est ce que vous en pensez
il ya plus de 10% qui ne payent pas
l'impôt en france 1 mais toujours pareil
quand vous prenez des mesures fiscales
évidemment ça peut pas être en faveur de
gens qui payent pas l'impôt puisque si
vous baissez les impôts ceux qui n'en
paient pas ils voient pas de mai là
dessus on peut trouver des mesures
soient sur la taxe d'habitation soit sur
la tva sur un certain nombre de mesures
mais nous sommes un des pays du monde où
la solidarité la répartition se fait le
plus et le mieux
donc il faut continuer de le faire
derrière pas de ya pas de sujet mais il
faut que l'état accepte quand même de
baisser la dépense publique par exemple
le président la république s'était
engagé une baisse du nombre de
fonctionnaires d'état ne pas des
fonctionnaires locaux considérable sur
cinq ans bon en réalité yamakasi pas la
taxe d'habitation va baisser pour
beaucoup de foyers vous avez des
réserves sur cette réforme pourquoi
parce qu'en réalité on a fait cette
suppression en tout cas pour 80 %
puisque les 20% autres on verra en 2023
on l'a fait sans avoir préalablement
fait la réforme l'eau fiscal de mai
locale c'est à dire que vous avez laissé
les collectivités en disant bas nous on
a les charges les dépenses on nous
supprime une recette
alors on fait du bric à brac à bon bah
alors finalement on va vous transférez
est ce qu'on avait donné au département
va vous leur donnez alors le département
de la lozère département abonder les
appartements du très grand n'importe
quoi peut-être qu'on aurait pu réfléchir
initialement à une nouvelle réforme
fiscale locale et à partir de là baisser
l'impôt mais baisser l'impôt pour
ensuite se dire bah mon fai
collectivités locales n'ont plus
d'argent pour faire les écoles les
crèches les machins c'est débile vous
n'êtes pas rassurez vous dites que c'est
débile vous n'êtes pas à rassurer par
les promesses du gouvernement de
compenser à l'euro près le répéter mais
de le dire vous dit on va compenser ça
veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que vous avez dit j'ai
supprimer un impôt local qui lui étaient
visibles identifiés et avec lequel les
mairies payer des dépenses que les gens
voyaient au quotidien la trèche
l'aménagement de la commune et ses 6 et
compenser ça veut quand même dire que
l'état va payer
ça veut donc dire que l'argent de vos
impôts va revenir d'une autre manière
sur la collectivité
une face à des visiteuses baisse puisque
par définition quand on dit je vous
suppriment ça mais je vais vous le
compenser a en réalité ça veut dire
dépenser galles donc bon voilà c'est la
fin de l'autonomie financière des
collectivités on a entendu puisque ça
fait énormément râler la sphère d'un
hold up
écoutez il ya encore pas longtemps notre
ami françois baroin disaient les
communes n'en peuvent plus on multiplie
les charges ont réduit de plus en plus
et l'autonomie de décision liautaud
louis financière maintenance et les
départements qu'ils disent moi j'ai
entendu valérie pécresse le dire pour
les régions rires d'un côté on dit il
faut décentraliser déconcentré plus d'un
autre côté on se dit bon bah on laisse
plus de moyens plus de pouvoir aux
collectivités il faut savoir ce qu'on
vous dit que le gouvernement oublier un
peu l'objectif de déficit de réduction
de la dette
en ce qui n'est pas assez rigoureux ce
budget c'est clair on vit à crédit et on
vit sur l'espoir que les taux d'intérêt
restent bas le plus longtemps alors
qu'on devrait économiser c'est ça que
vous disais je suis pas sûr qu'on soit
en capacité d'épargné en tout cas ne pas
s'avancer là encore davantage surtout
après le mouvement des gilet jaune roger
karoutchi
c'était aussi un naturel après un tel
mouvement je suis pas sûr que les gilet
jaune ou ceux qui étaient dans la rue
réellement au début je parle pas des
black blocs qui ensuite ont profité du
mouvement mais je suis pas sûr qu'il
soit ravi ravi des mesures qui ont été
prises parce qu'on parle d'un budget
pour les juges d'un budget en réaction
enfin ça c'est pardon c'est de la com
mais alors on parle en démesure gilet
jaune ya une part ce serait plus le
budget de l'état mais c'est le budget de
la sécurité sociale qui est bientôt
examiné une partie des des mesures pour
les jets pour les gilet jaune des
mesures d'urgence sont financés
actuellement par le budget de la
sécurité sociale il ya eu un amendement
pour revenir sur sa ce que c'est normal
pour vous d'avoir fait ça alors que
normalement
l'état n'a pas à faire ça apprendra la
sécu le gouvernement en tout cas il doit
compenser ça laurent allez je vais être
fort je suis pas sûr que les
gouvernements de droite ne l'est jamais
fait mais bon sauf que là c'était une
facile il ya des méthodes de commandes
et de manipulations comptables
pourraient réduire d'autant qu'on le
peut le déficit budgétaire de l'état
mais c'est absurde parce que il ya
encore un an nous disait la sécurité
sociale va mieux vous allez voir les
conflits sociaux vont être à l'équilibré
et puis finalement ils sont déficitaires
du bois parce que si vous mettez
évidemment une charge bas
vous êtes dans la grève le budget de la
sécurité sociale d'avoir mis des vous
avez entendu ce qu'a dit christian
eckert à l'ancien secrétaire d'état au
budget il a dit il n'y a pas besoin
d'avoir fait polytechnique pour
comprendre que le gouvernement veut
changer de modèle des class et qu on
était à l'équilibré mercredi le trou
pour dire que ça marche pas c'est pas
pour dire que ça marche pas c'est pour
malheureusement dire si on n'arrive pas
à réduire le déficit du budget de l'état
parce que c'est très lourd parce que
c'est très compliqué parce qu'on ne veut
pas prendre des mesures révolutionnaires
et donc on prend l'argent aveu d'échec
ou ah oui c'est un aveu d'échec puisque
en réalité on n'arrive pas réellement
réduire la masse et le poids de
l'administration dans ce pays elle et
roger karoutchi on passe au troisième
thème de cette émission
le sénat qui termine l'examen du projet
de loi sur le statut de l'élu
[Musique]
cette semaine les sénateurs ont voté
plusieurs mesures pour accroître le
pouvoir de police des mers on voit le
détail avant d'en parler
maillant vigreux c'est justement parce
qu'il faisait valoir son pouvoir de
police que le maire de signes dans le
var jean mathieu michel a été
mortellement renversé en août dernier un
fait divers qui a accéléré l'examen du
projet de loi engagement et proximité
projet qui vise à donner plus d'armes
juridique au maire pour renforcer leur
pouvoir d'action immédiat désormais ces
derniers pourront notamment sanctionné
par des amendes
les encombrements ou occupation du
domaine public mais aussi certaines
incivilités au trouble à l'ordre public
des amendes qui peuvent atteindre les
500 euros on a souhaité augmenter le
niveau de la membres pour qu'il y ait un
caractère plus dissuasif c'est important
et notamment aussi sur le pouvoir
d'astreinte qui est quand même essentiel
notamment et on l'a vu cet été avec le
décès du maire de signes sur des dépôts
sauvages en matière de déchets tout ce
qui de près ou de loin porte atteinte à
la fois de sécurité sur certains sujets
ou à la qualité de vie de nos
concitoyens dans les communes donc c'est
aussi une façon de résoudre des
problèmes du quotidien
ces derniers peuvent également recourir
à des mises en demeure en cas de non
respect du droit de l'urbanisme mais
aussi procédé à la fermeture
administrative des débits de boissons et
des établissements diffusant de la
musique
en cas de troubles à l'ordre public ou
d'infractions compétences dévolues
jusqu'à l'heure où seul préfet et pour
les aider à accomplir leur mission les
communes devront obligatoirement se
doter d'une assurance juridique
après deux semaines d'examen et près de
mille amendements le vote solennel du
texte est prévu au sénat le 22 octobre
prochain
roger karoutchi c'est un texte qui vous
a bien occupé à moins de 3 nuits
blanches cette semaine et de très
nombreux amendements examinés
est ce que vous êtes sur ce point
satisfait d'avoir accru les pouvoirs de
police du maire
à travers ce texte alors moi je suis un
opposant le problème ne se pose pas je
dois dire que le ministre sébastien
lecornu a été très à l'écouté des élus
locaux et du parlement
j'espère que ça se passera aussi bien à
l'assemblée nationale mais effectivement
on a beaucoup beaucoup travaillé je
une nuit sur ce texte c'était partie de
ce qui se passait avec plusieurs maires
agressé avec une espèce de situations
complètement folle où le maire avait le
sentiment qu'il avait la charge de taux
et le pouvoir de rien et donc c'était
assez normal qu'on retrouve un peu d
espace
on a profité d'ailleurs de ce texte non
seulement pour renforcer les pouvoirs de
police du maire
mais pour redéfinir un certain nombre
d'éléments entre communes et
intercommunalités parce que beaucoup y
met à la portée des tacles à des saisies
on n'a plus de pouvoir donc bon et je
trouve que le gouvernement bien avancé
puisque le ministre le contenu à
plusieurs reprises dit qu'il ne voulait
pas que les intercoms soit des pressions
sur les communes qu'il condamnait la loi
nôtre sur un certain nombre de sujets
donc on a pu avancer
donc vous pouvez vous montrez que vous
pouvez vous représentants de la droite
sénatoriale travailler main dans la main
avec le gouvernement sur certains textes
qu'il nécessite comme c'est le cas avec
ce qu'il a montré sa droite sa structure
mais ç'a toujours été sa lé sénat et
c'est pas le côté ce que vous êtes
macron compatibles ou gouvernementales
aux compatible au sénat on regarde ce
qui est le mieux et ce qui correspond à
l'intérêt général
on est en lien avec les maires avec les
élus locaux
et quand le gouvernement propose une
mesure qui va dans le bon sens on l'a
débat en l'amendant là ça répond à
toutes les violences les cas de violence
et contre les particules sincèrement
j'espère que ce texte ne sera pas de
nature à l'assemblée nationale et si ce
texte est publié tel qu'elle s'y est les
décrets d'application qui suivent
je pense que ça va dans le bon sens où
j'ai karoutchi la droite a donc été
constructives et vous une fois n'est pas
coutume vous vous êtes même mis d'accord
avec la gauche sur une mesure pour
réduire le nombre de nuitées possible à
la location sur airbnb alors qu'est ce
qui vous arrive vous fait ami ami avec
anne hidalgo vous êtes yes
non non non sûrement pas et
non moi je
je trouve que aujourd'hui par rapport
aux hôteliers qui ont des contraintes
considérables fiscal réglementaire et
c'est dire que on peut
cent vingt jours par an louer son
appartement de manière continue
plusieurs années d'affilée et cetera
c'est excessif parce que vous avez des
quartiers de paris mais aussi du
quartier dans les grandes villes de
province ou de banlieue où ça devient
très semblable vous avez des touristes
qui passent qui reviennent qui parce
qu'ils reviennent
mais il ya plus de vie de quartier il ya
plus de vide immeuble il ya plus de vie
sociale et à sang s'est passé
franchement quelle catégorie accepterait
qu'en parallèle des gens aient la
capacité de faire autant jeudi
si vous louez votre appartement deux
mois par an bon ça va vous restez quand
même celui qui est le propriétaire
légitime quatre mois par an plusieurs
années d'affilée
c2c de l'hôtellerie dissimulé alors
voila moi je n'ai pas de lien avec
airbnb que ces gens fassent de l'argent
c'est leur problème mais pas avec mon
texte pensé que la mesure sera de
détricoter je n'ai aucun souci comme le
gouvernement s'y est opposé il va là a
balayé à l'assemblée nationale mais je
trouvais que symboliquement dira airbnb
ou à tous ceux qui ne rêvent que dubé
risation de la société à un moment
attention un moment attention et des
gens qui vivent
il ya des il ya ceux qui
professionnellement son nom l'hôtellerie
qui n'ont pas être attaqué comme çà puis
il ya la vie des gens tout court voilà
la vie quotidienne donc non on va
terminer avec une image pour cette
émission l'assemblée qui a voté le
projet de loi bioéthique 359 voix pour
114 compte vote dans un calme relatif
après trois semaines de débats en séance
il n'y a pas eu de position de groupe
dans votre partie des républicains ce
que vous voterez ce texte qui arrive au
sénat
moi je suis quelqu'un d'extrêmement
construit et donc je fais partie de la
commission spéciale qui va travailler
sur ce texte bioéthique a priori comme
ça je suis plutôt favorable à la pma
mais j'ai des convictions religieuses
morales mentale et donc je veux faire
les deux mois de travail qui
les auditions je me dirai ma position au
terme je veut auditionner comprendre et
dire à ce moment là où j'en suis bien
rendez vous donc mois de janvier a
priori pour l'examen de la loi de
bioéthique et rendez vous également
cette semaine mardi à 14h sur lcp pour
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et à 14h également mercredi
sur public sénat pour les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement au sénat
très bonne chute de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires et à la semaine
prochaine cha cha
[Musique]